Réflexion, analyse avec Gérard
Araud, que vous connaissez bien,
ancien ambassadeur de France
aux États-Unis.
Monsieur Araud, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Vous avez écrit, dans un texte
en fin de semaine, ça peutsembls
pour forcer des cessez-le-feu,
une vrai négociation, il faut
armer encore plus l'Ukraine.Exp.
GÉRARD ARAUD, ancien ambassadeur
de France aux États-Unis
- Oui, parce que vous savez,dann
vient à la table de négociation
parce que soit on est le
vainqueur, soit on est le
vaincu, soit on se rend compte
qu'on ne peut pas l'emporter.
Alors, pour le moment, Poutine
pense qu'emporter.
Poutine n'ira pas à la table de
négociation, sauf si l'Ukraine
capituleur l'amener
à la table de négociation, la
seule alternative, c'est de
es armes aux Ukrainiens
de telle sorte qu'ils soient
capables de résister aux Russes
un certain moment,
Poutine dise : "Ça me coûte trop
cher, il vaut mieux, il vaut
e je négocie."
- On vient d'entendre avant
d'aller vous voir, Monsieur
Blinken qui dit : "On esten tras
appareils. Le problème, c'est
que les pilotes ukrainiens
ne peuvent pas conduire tous
les avions." Alors, commentvouss
pour armer l'Ukraine sans entrer
directement avec les forces
de l'OTAN, avec... etc.?
où, la limite?
- Alors, moi, ce que je
comprends, c'est que la Pologne,
et peut-être également
d'ailleurs la Roumanie et
d'autres pays, des anciens pays
de l'Est, possèdesssssss
MiG, et notamment des MiG-29,
qu'ils ont modernisés, qui ont
été modernisés d'a
avec du matériel américain.
Et donc, ce que les Polonais
disent aux América :
"Autorisez-nous à les transférer
aux Ukrainiens, mais également,
prometteles remplales remplalesr
par des avions de combat. Parce
que si nous, les Polonais, nous
nous dessaisissons de nos
avions, évidemment, nous nous
sentirons vulnérables."
Donc, je crois que l'idée,
c'est la fourniture aux pilo
ukrainiens, qui devraient savoir
les utiliser, des MiG-29 que
possèdent encore la Pologne.
- Parce qu'évidemment, on ne
peut pas leur donner des pilotes
polonais ou des pilotes
de pays membres de l'OTAN.
- Non, ce serait un acte de
guerre. Ça voudrait dire que des
Polonais, voire des Américains,
des Français, abattent ou se
battent avec des avions russes.
Ce serait un acte de guerre
entre le pays, la Pologne,
les États-Unis, la France
et la Russie. Et cela, depuis
le début, nous l'avons dit,
nous ne voulons pas y arriver.
- Est-ce qu'on peut, en donnant
des avions, en prêtant des
avions polonais, arriver au même
but, c'est-à-dire une sorte
de zone d'exclusion aérienne?
- Non, la raison de l'exclusion
aérienne, c'est, vous savez,
avec des moyens à la fois
antiaériens et aériens,
d'interdire à l'aviation ennemie
de se déployer dans cet espace.
Là, ce serait simplement
de donner moyens aux Ukrainiens
de se battre d'égal à égal
avec l'aviation...
avec l'aviation russe.
Donc, apparemment, vous avez
raison, comme vous l'avez dit,
c'est un domaine, l'aviation, ùu
les Russes ont une supériorité,
une grande supériorité. Ce
serait une manière de rétablir
ce rapport de force, toujours
dans cette logique d'amener les
Russes à la conclusion qu'ils
ne parviendront pas à leurs fins
par des moyens militaires
et qu'ils doivent donc négocier.
- Déjà, qu'on soit à la 12e
journée, qu'est-ce que ça
vous dit sur, quand même,
la résistance ukrainienne?
Et donc peut-être cette envie
qui va se développer chez
gocier? Il ne
veut pas non plus s'enliser
en Ukraine, on imagine.
- Ah, vous savez, excusez-moi,
mais 12 jours de guerre,
ce n'est rien. Ce n'est rien.
Nous entrons dans une guerre qui
va durer des semaines et peut-
être des mois. C'est une vraie
guerre. Nous avons oublié, nous,
les Occidentaux, et peut-être
encore plus les Canadiens,
vu votre géographie, nous avons
oublié ce que c'était, une vraie
guerre. Une vraie guerre, c'est
sale, ça dure et ça détruit.
Eh bien, nous allons... nous
sommes au moment où Poutine
pense qu'il peut gagner. Il est
évident cier
et faire des concessions, cela
apparaîtrait aujourd'hui comme
un échec. Il n'a pas atteint
ce moment-là. Il va donc, aue, e
pour essayer de briser
la résistance des Ukrainiens
dans les semaines qui viennent.,
on le sait, on a vu,
impuissants, en fin de semaine
encore, l'échec des pourparlersr
des progrès? Est-ce que
les civils, on peut mieux
- Bien, je viens de lire, juste
avant votre émission, je viens
usse
des Affaires étrangères a
annoncé que la Russie était
r des couloirs
humanitaires à partir d'un
certain nombre de villes, Mariol
et Kiev. Là, c'est évidemment
que les Russes ont un intérête s
civiles soit réduit,
mais sur le terrain, c'estffici.
Et on a en particulier
l'impression que les Russes
ne contrôlent pas bien leurs
troupes, que les communications
tactiques, n'est-ce pas,
entre les soldats sur le front
et le commandement ne sont pas
très bonnes. Donc, ils vont...
J'espère que ça marchera,
ça permettra sans doute
à un certain nombre de civils
de se tirer de ces villes
assiégée
pas d'illusions, ce n'est pas la
solution à tous les problèmes.
Il y aura évidemment
des inci
- Bon, pour résumer, Gérard
Araud, vous dites que pour qu'il
y ait une réelle négociation,
il doit y avoir un rapport dd
force changé, donc un afflux
d'armes et de matériel militaire
du côté de l'Ukraine
si on veut la paix.
- Oui, c'est ça qui est
paradoxal. Et en particulier
par rapport, je dirais,
à nos consciences d'Occidentaux.
Nous avons la chance incroyable
d'avoir connu la paix depuis
1945. 75 ans de paix. Moi, quand
j'étais enfant, mes parents,
mes grands-parents me parlaient
des deux guerres mondiales.
Nous avons eu trois générations
sans guerre. Nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre cela.
Mais voilà, c'est une guerre,
c'est une vraie guerre. Et pour
obliger, pour amener l'ennemi,
car c'est un ennemi, la Russie,
à la négociation, il faut
qu'elle se sente obligée.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut qu'elle
pense qu'elle ne peut pas
l'emporter à un prix acceptable
pour elle. Il y aura donc
devant nous, je le crains,
beaucoup de destruction,
de victimes civiles.
Ce sera un long conflit.
- Gérard Araud, merci
de nous avoir parlé.
Merci on se reparle.
- Je vous en prie.